ja das muss sich überlegen was wir
ausgelassen haben die versuche mich so
groß aber eine scheiße zu dem möglichen
jahre herzen kommt zu einem neuen video
das gefühlt das erste video seit
dreieinhalb jahren ist in dem ich nicht
auf hilfen die reagiere zu diesem zwecke
habe ich mir zwei alte bekannte in
dieser runde eingeladen zwar einmal mag
und anderen stelle und läutete wir
spielen heute ein darunter sei auch in
diesem moment würde dieses video seht
her wo es angekommen ist sind auch auf
den kanälen von maxxim luca jeweils
einige skipper online gekommen also
täglich auf jeden fall auch ab wir sind
eine beschreibung verlinkt wir spielen
jetzt bei mir eine runde mit deutschen
prominenten nicht nur youtuber sondern
auch alle möglichen anderen musiker
jonas da vielleicht auch ein oder zwei
drin aber wie das ganze passiert auch
das glaub ich klar manchmal einfach
begriffe also einer malt und der rest
erlebt aber ich möchte wohl leute für
sich jetzt irgendwie kopf hängen
geblieben schaut auf jeden fall die
videos erwachsene luca außerdem versteht
ihr das hier
ich bin mal los geht's ich habe dort die
götter gerade selbst eingetragen ich
weiß nicht was es ist wie kannst du es
ist nicht direkt ich bin direkt drauf
gekommen
oh mein gott aber ich finde das linke
das ist das ist ganz weit hergeholt wenn
man es weiß nicht wann es aber als ob
sollten drin sein
alles klar war das ist ja auch ich nehme
das das wissen schwerer
ich habe nicht mal gemalt einfach nur
gewartet dass frank walter
[Gelächter]
ja du dummer junge als junge leute das
ist prima maximal der weißen brachten
sie können wir fertig sind hier machst
du hast immer noch fragt mich doch nicht
immer richtig was passiert wäre ja auch
so erste gewesen okay aber gut dass
sogar dass thomas gottschalk gekommen
ist zu krank
das wird ja ich hatte aber vorher auch
thomas gottschalk und dann dachte ich
dass ein zug der wohin das ist gar nicht
mal so wichtig für die person
gabriel ich weiß als achso
wie konnte sie alle drauf kommen nur
wegen typen fahren ja ich dachte james
dean im cabrio danach die forderung ist
falsch einfach nur noch freunde
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
ist ja okay was schwierig es ist also
komplett konträr zu dem sinn dieses
spiel ist das andere starten bevor denn
[Gelächter]
ich habe warte warte jetzt habt ihr das
auch so längst wenn ich diese schwere
erreichte schnell machen ich habe schon
so direkt eingegeben labore nicht
gesehen was man hat
[Gelächter]
zusammen
[Musik]
oh nein ihr wisst ihr warum das so ist
weil bei macbook air max wir nicht
wieder weg
warum seid ihr bereit
das wird immer mehr mit was was für
rot-rot nicht hatten
doch etwas gelassener in die versuchung
ist so groß dass man so eine scheiße zu
dem wirklich natürlich ein ganz klarer
fall
zum nachdenken leute hätten angegeben
es ist falsch ich sehe es jetzt erst
selbst betrifft und ich wusste selbst
wieder zweiter
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
ich weiß nicht wo mein gott hält alles
schon die frage ist nur noch wie schnell
ein okay natürlich hätte bei den
grün-weißen letzte runde
jetzt ist letzte runde
jetzt ist letzte runde ich werde dich
nie auswählen
[Gelächter]
ja da die tagebaue schnell damit wir die
punkte doch am markt gehört ihr seht ihr
am rand ich bin zweiter platz marx war
erster platz luca letzter platz und an
dieser stelle danke ich euch dass ihr
bei dieser sehr sinnvollen runde
zugeschaut habe wir haben uns die beste
mühe gegeben sehr korrekt zu erraten und
alles korrekt zu malen die beiden sind
jetzt einfach ich vorgeschlagen video
abchecken macht's gut und bis bald